[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends this is Doug Batchelor
would you like to hear an amazing fact
among the first wave of English settlers
had set foot on Plymouth Rock in 1629
was a Puritan named John Endicott who
came to serve as the first governor of
the Massachusetts Bay Colony in
approximately 1630 as his children
looked on Endicott planted one of the
first fruit cheese to be cultivated in
the new world it was a pear sapling
imported from his estate across the
Atlantic
at the time he said I hope the tree will
love the soil of the old world and no
doubt when we have gone the tree will
still be alive the tree did outlive John
Endicott and his children's children and
many generations that followed by 1763
colonists noted that the tree dubbed the
Endicott pear tree was already very old
and showing signs of decay but still it
continued to thrive and bear fruit in
fact in 1809 the tree had such notoriety
that even President John Adams received
a special delivery of its pears after
holding fast through scorching heat
freezing cold and multiple hurricanes
which battered the region in the 19th
century the tree became a cherished
fixture in the community erected a
wooden fence to protect it as early as
1852 folks were already proclaiming
Endicott spera tree as the oldest
cultivated fruit tree in North America
the old tree was nearly destroyed by
vandals in 1964 who chopped off the
branches and cut the trunk off about six
feet above the ground still it recovered
and sprouted new branches and more fruit
although it's parris have been described
as medium in size unattractive and
coarse textured the
trees amazing tenacity overshadows its
mediocre fruit today the tree is
surrounded by a chain-link fence on an
inconspicuous plot of land hidden behind
an office building on an Endicott Street
in Danvers Massachusetts it might be
hard to believe but this original
American settler is still alive today
and still bearing fruit after three
hundred and eighty three years friends
you know the Bible says there's many
things a man can learn from a tree stay
with us we're gonna learn more as
amazing facts brings you this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 the Bible
together and we ask for the Holy Spirit
once again to come and guide our hearts
and our minds be with those who are
listening Lord and may we all come to a
clear and a full understanding of what
the word says because you said we shall
know the truth and the truth will set us
free be with us this evening in Jesus
name Amen
amen pastor dougie opened the program
but talking about a remarkable tree I
mean no trees live for a long time but
this one first planted by the early
settlers that came over from Europe to
the United States and I understand it
still living today yep that's amazing
Paris still produces pears and you know
I believe this because you've been to
our cabin up in the hills and when we
moved to that land 40 years ago there
were old fruit trees there from settlers
that came during the gold rush and those
fruit trees as of last week were still
there out in the field and some of the
original trees and again the pears
aren't that good but they're pretty
tenacious and so I believe every word of
it imagine that you know and that could
be what David was think
when he said in Psalm 1 if you go to the
second verse speaking about a man who
survives and thrives it says his delight
is in the law of the Lord and in his law
he meditates day and night he will be
like a tree planted by the rivers of
water that brings forth its fruit in
season whose leaf will not wither and
whatever he does will prosper you know
and again the Lord says that those who
are faithful they will their days in
heaven will be like the days of a tree
Isaiah 65 verse 22 but you know David
was comparing a person who listens to
the law of the Lord and loves the law of
the Lord and follows it that person will
be like a tree that is planted and that
is fruitful the Lord wants us to have
the fruits of the Spirit in our life and
a determination to put the Word of God
before us and by His grace and Spirit to
obey his law helps us to have fruitful
lives and there might be people out
there wondering you don't hear much
about it these days but the truth is not
changed and God still wants Christians
to keep the Ten Commandments not to be
saved but because we are saved and Jesus
said if you love me keep my Commandments
if you'd like to better understand this
relationship between love the Lord and
the law we have a special offer for you
tonight we have a study guide that is
called written in stone and we'll be
happy to send this to anybody who gives
us a call again the study guide is
called written in stone and the phone
number to receive this free resource is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is our resource line
again the number is 883 five sixty seven
forty seven you can ask for the study
guide called written in stone and we'll
be happy to send that to anybody who
calls and asks you know pastor day we
also have some folks who are listening
via the internet outside of North
America and they can also participate in
this free offer by simply going to the
amazing facts website and they can
actually do this Bible study for free
online and they can actually study this
lesson called written in stone it's all
about God's law
I think it'll be a great blessing to
those who study it again if you have a
Bible related question friends then I'm
gonna call here to the studio this
evening is 804 six three seven two nine
seven 804 63 72 97 well pastor Doug
we're ready to go to the phone lines our
first caller for this evening is Sophia
listening in Ontario
Sophia welcome to the program hi pastor
Doug hi pastor us my question is the
Bible says that our sins will be cast to
the bottomless sea is where if we ask
for forgiveness so on Judgment Day will
our sins be read out aloud for everyone
to hear that are already forgiven no
that's a quick 2 letter one-word answer
if we have come to Christ and confess
their sentence and repent of our sins
then he washes away our sins and in the
day of the judgement now everybody does
stand before the Lord the Bible is
pretty clear all will stand before the
judgment see Christ stands in our behalf
he pleads his blood and all of our sins
have been paid for and so they're
basically under the blood as the song
says so yeah thank heavens that when we
repent of our sins and confess our sins
and forsake our sins God says he cast
them into the depths of the sea and I
heard a pastor say and he sets up a no
fishing sign so he doesn't doesn't want
them being fished up again okay matter
of fact I think it's an easy kiyul 18 it
says that if the wicked man turns from
his wickedness all of his sins will not
be remembered and so there's a lot of
promises that's a relief isn't it me and
you hey god bless and you will enjoy our
study guide on the law we'll send you a
free copy if you'd like Sophia the
number to call again is 800 eight three
five six seven four seven you can answer
the study guide cold written in stone
I'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks unless Collies Dennis
and his listening in California and
Dennis welcome to the program yes thank
you very much
for being there for us thank you in
light of the struggle in Israel today
with the Palestinians and stuff like
that I've been wondering if when I think
it was in 2nd Samuel it said that God
didn't intend for us to have kings and
yet I think Israel said we want to have
Kings like the other tribes right in the
land and it just seems like every sin
from the apple on the tree the multiple
wives of Abraham and Jacob every human
idea seems to sidetrack God's intentions
and I'm just wondering what did he
intend for Israel to be a strong
conquering dominant nation or almost an
angelic example to the world well he he
said that he wanted them to be and
pastor also looked this up I know where
it is in 2nd Peter but it's also in I
think Leviticus maybe even Exodus where
it says he wanted to be a nation of
kings and priests I think it's even
repeated in Revelation that they will
live and reign with Christ so he didn't
want them to have a single king over
them but the Lord said I am their king
and so I'm sure every tribe was to have
leaders and judges and patriarchs but
they were to be a nation of priests that
were to bring the other nations to God
they were to make atonement and
intercede and lead the other nations to
God and it was really during the time of
Solomon they got as close as they could
get to the ideal and I know that during
the time of Solomon he of course was a
king but like when the Queen of Sheba
and other nations were coming to Israel
to learn about their God that had
blessed them so much that was what God
wanted them to do is to lead the others
to him to be a light on a hill as a
kingdom but he wanted he wanted the
people to trust in him as king and not
to look to a single man
you know what could there be an
application to today well now it's the
church Peter says now we are to be a
nation of we're a royal priesthood we're
a holy nation and so we are a nation of
kings and priests that you know the Lord
says he's given us a kingdom and it
tells us that we're a holy priesthood so
now it really applies to the church both
Jew and Gentile is there any hope for
what's going on over there I hope so I
think in one week pastor Ross and I will
be there and we're watching the
headlines as they're lobbing missiles
back and forth between Syria we're going
anyway well the way from the point of
Armageddon yeah well you know what you
would be interested I just finished a
three-part series last week on
Armageddon and ah let me see he yeah you
can probably get that on my Facebook
page just go to the Facebook page and
scroll down a little bit you'll see all
the messages Armageddon part 1 2 & 3 and
I talked about that ah you'll enjoy that
great well thank you appreciate your
call take care bye bye
our next caller that we have is Barbara
listening in South Carolina Barbara
welcome to the program thank you my
question is yeah I would like to preface
that was saying I respect you both very
much
I watched the prophecy co.com 2012 a
friend sent it to me and I watched all
of the videos and I decided I've got to
go visit this church I did the church I
got baptized in 2013 my husband never
did join but our new year's resolution
was to observe the Sabbath every Sabbath
since January 1st 2013 I
I was recently dispeller shipped from my
church and we had started a new one and
I was dispelling because I wanted
to study
about the Godhead or the God the Holy
Spirit I had I had been exposed to you
know the truth about the Father the one
true God and that he has a truly
begotten son
I watched a sort of a debate that Doug
Batchelor did with a guy named Steve I
think I saw it yesterday yeah and I
would I would like to ask you to have a
similar situation with a one true god
believer and our representative will
come to you to your venue to where
you're comfortable and in a respectful
way to be able to discuss this because
it's a hot topic it is a hot topic right
I mean I wouldn't just fellowship
because I wanted to study this right and
it's like there's something wrong with
this picture well now our so if you were
gonna now one thing you're asking about
a possible debate and that really I
would I would answer in a different
venue than our calling program right now
but it did you have a question on the
subject of the Trinity in the Godhead I
still have several but I'll ask a
different question okay I'll ask you -
I'll ask a different question what is we
know about the book of life I've heard
about that but then what is this book
there's there's an are there three books
mentioned in the Bible or are there two
books and one of them I think they
brought up yesterday was the book of
remembrance yeah well and pastor Ross
might chime in
Moses talks about a book then there are
places he says Lord you know take my
name out of your book singular in Daniel
it says everyone that has found written
in the book in Revelation it talks about
the books were open and so there's been
much discussion about is it one book
that contains like you know the Bible is
one book with many books in it so some
have wondered is it
you know God let me just tell you what
we know the Bible says he has there is a
record of all those who have witness for
Christ talks about those who thought
upon his name there's a record of every
idle word we've spoken the Bible says
all of the books are open and the dead
were judged out of those things written
in the book it says we're judged
according to our works we're saved by
grace but our works show if we've been
saved by grace so the book our books
contain at least a record of those who
have accepted the plan of salvation 1 is
the book of life and then there are the
it's the book of Deeds pastor oz I don't
know if yep you have a book as pastor
Doug mentioned where Jesus said every
idle word that a man speaks he shall
give an account of so there's some form
of record whether that's a book of all
of the sins that are committed or words
spoken foolishly there is a book of
remembrance that the Bible speaks of
where David says you save my tears in
symbolic language a poetic bought
language my tears are recorded in your
in you keep them in your bottle or book
or remembrance on those lines it talks
about the sufferings that Christians go
through there is a remembrance of that
and of course the book of life as you
mentioned yeah the book of life is
mentioned in Revelation several times so
I don't know if that helps a little bit
and I'm one you know we do have a lesson
we can send you a free copy of that and
it's called facing the judge and I maybe
you'll find some more yeah I think that
actually has some more of those
references in there we'll send your FREE
copy of that and Thank You Barbara
appreciate your call as far as
possibility of a future debate we'd
probably do that through our office if
we set that up if we do we'll announce
it and let everyone know the verse
you're referring to about a book of
remembrance is Malachi chapter 3 verse
16 yes folks about that
our next caller that we have is Geneva
listening in Bloomfield Colorado Geneva
off from the program thank you thank you
well my question is in Hebrews 6 I'm
going to say verse 4 I think okay if it
is impossible for those who are
enlightened and have tasted of the
heavenly gift and were made partakers
and whenever they ask thee where is it
okay
verse 6 and when they fall away to renew
them again into repentance seeing that
they crucified to themselves the Son of
God afresh and put him to an open shame
well I I've been baptized a bunch of
times and and I hope he can't be
baptized too many times I don't know I
guess I wasn't ready until about 30
years ago but anyway
are you wondering if these I'm sorry go
ahead do things yeah I do things that I
know I shouldn't but I love the Lord I
don't you know I'm and that that verse
scares me alright well let's first look
at the verse and find out what it
doesn't mean a lot of people read
Hebrews chapter 6 verse 4 through 6 and
they think it's saying that if a person
sins after they know the truth that then
there for forever loss that's like the
unpardonable sin if that's true a Peter
who walked with Jesus tasted of the
heavenly gift went out and performed
miracles and then denied Christ
ultimately was swearing and cursing how
could he be forgiven but he was and
you've got several examples in the Bible
of people like David who you know was
spirit-filled working for the Lord God
was fighting side by side with him he
killed Goliath and then he takes the
guy's wife and has him killed
you would think well that would mean
that there's no recovery for him so this
verse is not saying that when believers
make a big mistake are even backslide
that there's no hope you see what I'm
saying first let's decide what it
doesn't mean because otherwise when
Moses lost his temper or when Moses
murdered somebody
that would mean there's no more hope for
him so this verse is not saying that I
think the verse is speaking using Greek
terms for their ongoing verbs if a
person continues in known rebellion
after they've received all the fullness
of God in other words they've God's
given them the best of his spirit and
he's given them clear understanding of
the truth and they've tasted the powers
of the age to come if they turn their
back persistently on the best that God
has to offer he's saying what else can
God do when he gives the best and it
rolls off their back so that's why it
says in verse 7 for the earth two drinks
in the rain and the water that comes
upon it and bears herbs it receives
blessings but if someone is rejecting
the rain of the Holy Spirit
they'll grieve away the Holy Spirit so
if you're still sensitive to the Spirit
of God if you've made mistakes you
confess you repent of your mistakes and
God's mercy is available as long as
we're willing to really repent he is
still willing to really forgive can you
think of anybody in the Bible that asked
God for mercy that didn't get mercy well
no I mean he even forgave the Ninevites
when he had already pronounced their
judgment when they repented he forgave
him so God is very merciful even King
Manasseh who had his own children
offered to pagan gods and killed the
prophet Isaiah terrible King he repented
God forgave them
I mean God is so merciful so don't get
discouraged and just know God is a
better forgiver than you are a sinner
okay okay and I know I'm only one
question but you need be baptized too
many times well I want to overdo it but
you know the Bible never gives a number
saying you know once you get baptized
over 70 times seven it's too many
I think baptism ought to be like
marriage where you hope you only do it
once
sometimes it happens more than once so
you know you need to take it very
seriously and there may be times where
you you know divorce yourself from the
Lord and you need to get remarried so
you know it's but there's no prescribed
number in the Bible that you know after
10 baptisms it doesn't count anymore
alrighty well thank you very much for
your question on Doug a man well he's
still working on your hearty you
wouldn't have calls ok thank you so much
thank you know we do have a book we'll
send you a free copy of riches of His
grace the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called riches of His grace we'll be
happy to send that to you and anybody
who calls and asks our next caller that
we have is Jed listening from Michigan
Jed welcome to the program it's how are
you we're doing well thank you yourself
I'm doing fine yesterday hi how are you
doing good good your question here right
now there's no holy spirit or is not God
and now I'm hearing that Jesus is not
God and so I'm wondering if you could
explain Hebrews chapter 1 down through 6
7 8 10 down through there it sounds to
me that God Himself is calling Jesus God
so can you clear that a little bit yeah
well first of all Jesus meets every
definition of God He is God the Son he's
a hundred percent God the Bible says
he's not supposed to worship anybody but
God but you read here in Hebrews chapter
1 verse 6 God said let all the angels of
God worship Him well when the Apostle
John tried to worship an angel angel
says don't do it you're only supposed to
worship God and but Jesus when he rose
from the dead
it says they worshiped him and so
Bible says that God created everything
in the beginning well the Bible says
Jesus created everything all things that
were made were made by him the Bible
says there's no Savior but Jehovah well
the Bible says Jesus is a savior the
Bible says God and God only can forgive
sin well the Bible says that Jesus can
forgive sin the Bible says only God
knows the thoughts of men's hearts well
jesus knew what was in man so you you go
through all the definitions go ahead
you're saying something if we worship
Jesus then we're putting an idol before
the father before God and yes it's a
worship idols no well then why did your
name no yeah I haven't but I'm not
surprised my question would be why would
Jesus say when he rose from the dead
all hail I mean that's he's inviting
them to worship insist and they
worshiped him so why would Jesus tell
them to break the commandments the
father is constantly trying to glorify
the Son and the son the father you know
I think the verse of you referring to
there makes it quite clear where in
verse 8 Paul who we believe wrote the
book of Hebrews is quoting from the Old
Testament and he says but to the son he
says this is God the Father speaking to
the son your throne O God is forever and
ever
so here the father referencing Christ
and referring to him as God you can't
give more of a testimony than that yeah
if you're not gonna believe the
testimony of God
what a higher authority do you appeal to
absolutely yes oh very good hey we
appreciate your questions Jed and you
know I'm just I've just completed a new
book dealing with a subject of
understanding the mystery of the Trinity
and not that anyone understands at all
but we're gonna do our best and we'll we
can also send you copied the book right
now that's called the Trinity is it
biblical where we talk about some of
these issues appreciate your question
we're gonna go back to the phones and
just a moment friends going to take a
drink of water we do have some lines
open give us a call 800 God says 800 for
six three seven two nine
seven coming right back stay tuned Bible
answers live will return in a moment
amazing facts has impacted manage praise
God for amazing facts amazing facts
actually did have an impact is full
process getting to where I am today I
began reading the Bible when I got
baptized into seventh then I realized
that there had to be more the light is
really doing that is the life that he's
coming this message was so powerful I
swear he goes amazing facts more than 45
years of reclaiming God's message around
the world and in the logo pops across
amazing facts presents I've listened to
a lot of different ministers but he was
this was the first time that he's
actually saying something where I had to
grab my Bible actually pick it up and
I've never heard this before let me let
me look through and find this that I
just couldn't get enough and so I
started doing Bible studies every single
one of these guys started being changed
including myself my question was why did
that happen to me God the Lord was able
to reach out and I actually saw him as a
father I lost everything and that was
when I realized that it was God missing
in my life I went to a prophecy seminar
which knocked me out this message was so
powerful and so irrefutable
I just went this is real this is this is
amazing every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need for a fuller richer
more confident life you're listening to
Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
my name is John Ross we're gonna go to
our next caller we have marked listening
in Indianapolis mark bought from the
program thank you for your patience and
your question i I was on in a medical
study and the conversation started in
basically an activist where talks about
having no images in the sky on the
ground or under the ground I believe I
don't have the exact right in front of
me and then the conversation went on do
well then why did God instruct the
Levites to put too large share of them
on the Erica of the Covenant and then we
began talking about the snake that Moses
was told to make with and they have them
gaze upon it and then and no one really
had a good answer why kind of after the
fact those were instructed to be built
and then we kind of digress into manger
scenes which may or may not be related
yeah I think the key first of all
they're quoting from the second
commandment which says you're not to
make the likeness of anything in the
heaven above the earth beneath the water
under the earth and bow down thyself to
them and serve them so God does not have
any commandment against making effects
simile of something
because when you think about it yeah God
told Solomon to make twelve oxen and put
it under the labor and that was the
temple that Solomon built later God told
Moses to have the women inscribe angels
on the curtain on the veil curtain the
priests had a pomegranate on the bottom
of his garment well that's an image of
something so but the thing was they were
not to worship those things and so if
you have a photograph now there is one
denomination that if they don't even
allow photographs but if you have a
photograph in your wallet of your
grandkids or your kids that's a likeness
I suppose there's some grandparents that
do worship them but you know the idea is
you're not to have anything to be an
idol or an image of a God and that's
idolatry now there are a number of
churches that make statues of Peter
James John and Mary and people pray to
them or the various saints that is
forbidden but to have a picture of your
your son or your daughter your wedding
picture on your piano or your wall
you're not praying to it there's nothing
wrong with that so the commandment is
not just don't make them it says do not
make them and see the sentence doesn't
end don't make them and bow down thyself
to them so just an issue of worship
which the issue of worship is somewhat
subjective on the viewers art well it
can be but yeah if a person sings you
know if a person's kneeling before an
image in burning a candle well that's
you know because you know I talked to my
Roman Catholic friends and they said
we're not worshipping this statue of
Mary I said well look when you're
kneeling before it and burning a candle
of when you're praying this well that's
just to help us visualize Mary I said
I'm sorry that even the Buddhists when
they kneel before a statue of Buddha
they know that statue is not the real
Buddha and so you know you can't yeah I
don't think the excuse works when you
take it that far
so yeah we shouldn't be prostrating
ourselves before these things and
bringing you
some countries and they bring gifts and
flowers and food and said it before
these statues and that's idolatry but
having a photograph or when God said to
put angels on top of the ark let's just
to create an image of what heaven is
like we're not to pray to the ark or to
any Idol hey thank you very much you
would enjoy the lesson we're offering
tonight it contains the commandments and
that's called written in stone the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can answer the study
guide called written in stone we have
David listening in Ohio David welcome to
the program
hi hello pastor Doug how are you today
good thanks for calling good excellent I
have a question but I also have a
request here in Cleveland Ohio area we'd
like to see perhaps a little more
evangelism out here and if it would be
possible at some point we'd love to see
your amazing facts to come out here and
do an evangelistic series it's been a
while and I've noticed that it really
doesn't get over to the north coast as
much so you tell them send us an
invitation I don't think I've ever done
a meeting in Ohio I love to come back
yeah I'd love that I love to help
orchestrate that if possible my one
question is in regards to the first
angels message yeah and in it it starts
out by saying this angel was proclaiming
the everlasting gospel and I've been
reading areas where it talks about
preaching the gospel and I see where
Jesus preached the kingdom of the gospel
the also Paul and Barnabas preached the
kingdom of God and then it even says in
Galatians three eight that I faded the
the gospel was preached to Abraham so
that tells me that the gospel the same
gospel has been preached from Genesis to
Revelation and is unchanging and I'm
noticing in chapter 14 of revelation
14:7 talking about to worship Him who
made the heaven the earth the sea in the
springs of water on can you elaborate on
that and how that identifies God's
authority over the earth and how it
points to the fourth commandment yeah
now for our friends listening we're
talking about Revelation chapter 14
these are three angel mess
is they go to the world immediately
prior to the second coming of Jesus and
it talks about preaching the everlasting
gospel and in that first message it says
worshipping Him that made well I think
that we know much of the first world
countries now they don't believe that
God made anymore they don't believe in
God as a creator in fact every Sabbath
day when you think about it we're
remembering that God is the Creator
because you know he made all things in
six days and he made one more day to
remember
he's a creator and that's why it says in
the fourth commandment for in six days
the Lord made every time we remember the
Sabbath we're remembering that in six
days God made the heaven the earth and
the sea that's the same phrase that you
find here in Revelation chapter 14
worship Him that made the heaven the
earth the sea in the springs of water
and so we're being called back to
worship God as creator and we've got a
lesson that talks about that
and I think people would enjoy our study
guide called angel messages from space
talks about the three angels messages
just a very important study and we'll be
able to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number he's 883 five six
seven four seven and asked for the study
guide called angel messages from space
and if you have a Bible question our
phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven we
have Marcus listening from Alabama
Marcus welcome to the program hey thank
you so much how you doing pastors doing
great thanks for calling thank you hey I
just had one question I've been studying
concerning the endtime and this gospel
when Jesus were tell them two signs that
would happen before he wouldn't come yes
but I ran across something that I kind
of just need a little bit more
clarification on this I've been praying
it asking for some clarification his
second Thessalonians 2 verses one
through four and really pertaining to
verses three and four it let no man
deceive you by any means for that day
will not come unless there come the
falling away first and the man of sin is
revealed the son of perdition who
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or that is worshipped
so that he sits as God in the temple of
God showing himself he is God that's the
one you want right yes sir so when I'm
looking at that it's actually talking
about the devil himself not necessarily
a man in flesh well yeah well yes and no
of course the devil would would enjoy
doing that even vicariously through any
man but when you think about the beast
power in Revelation it says for it is
the number of a man so it's a it's a
position that is held by a man now
the Protestants and I don't want to
anger any of my Orthodox or Catholic
friends but the Protestants
traditionally believed if you ask Martin
Luther or John Wesley or John Calvin
they all believed this was talking about
the Pope because when it says he sits in
the temple of God showing himself he is
God they weren't thinking of rebuilding
the Jewish temple they were thinking
that the church is the temple of God
jesus said destroyed this temple made
with hands three days I'll raise it up
he spoke of his body Church is called
the body of Christ and they said well
here the Pope says he's the universal
father of the temple of God the church
and so the Protestant leaders always
applied that verse to the position of
the Pope which was held by a man so I
know that's probably earth-shaking for
some people listening but it's not new
it's very old and I say that in love but
that's just the fact of later how the
Protestants viewed that verse
so the charismatic stood a there they're
thinking more of a demonic incarnation
that is going to sort of be a political
religious leader of the world so they've
kind of gotten away from the traditional
Protestant view so what was your
specific question on this verse well I
guess it was there because well another
part of it was when it says he will be
revealed does that mean somebody exposes
him if it is a person inflation
when you get to Revelation it tells us
that circumstances will really force the
hand of the beast so starts out speaking
like a lamb but ends up speaking like a
dragon and so is it becomes obvious what
power is behind him he starts out lamb
like like Christ ends up dragon like and
so along the way he's revealed okay hey
which will be yeah you know we have a
lesson I'd like to send you a lesson on
it about who is the Antichrist and all
you'll need to do is call and ask for it
we're happy to send it to you Marcus the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask for the study guide called
who is the Antichrist gets right into
this backstabbing and references this
verse as well as several others that you
find in the book of Revelation next
caller that we have is sue also
listening in Alabama sue welcome to the
program hi good thank you for calling
and waiting thank you for having my
question is I was been baptized a couple
years back and I understand that you're
forgiven and everything but I was
wondering how can you write forgive
yourself because it's like you always
bring in it you always think about the
stuff that you've doing so I guess I'm
wondering how can you get going you know
well that's a good question you know I
think all of us have done things where
we deeply regret and we're sorry
and you tell god you're sorry and I
believe you know in my own case I
believe that God forgives but whenever
for whatever reason that memory comes
back he kind of cringe and then I remind
myself God says if you repent and
confess your sins and this is a first
John chapter 1 verse 9 I think he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness claim the promise that
he forgives and he cleanses from all
unrighteousness then we've got to be
careful that we don't set up our opinion
as a higher tribunal than God in other
words if God says look I've forgiven you
and you see how but I haven't forgiven
myself and God is thinking who do you
think you are do you think your opinions
more important in my work if I say
you're forgiven
now the devil will bring to our memory
our past mistakes and as Martin Luther
used to say you cannot prevent the birds
from flying over your head but do not
let them make a nest in your hair those
thoughts may come but when they come
just reject them and say that sin is now
under the blood of Jesus and then move
on okay okay we are to pray and believe
try to trust the Lord and we we have
we've got a lesson that we can give you
that talks about the grace of God well
you know the book you mentioned a little
earlier riches of His grace is a
fantastic book the number to call is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
line you can answer the book called
riches of His grace I'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks we
have Marla who is listening in Maryland
oh hi pastors I just have a question my
Bible study group where we were studying
while we still are studying Daniel and
revelation and so you know those two
books go together like peas and carrots
right and I think it was I think it was
in revelation 22 where John is shown the
vision of the river water of life
careers okay and then so John is who was
he talking to us at Gabriel there well
so it calls him the angel of the Lord
many think it was Gabriel but I don't
know that muses Gabriel's name there I
don't think it does but so John was
talking to an angel regarding the river
and went back in Daniel 12 this is my
question is kind of trivial but it just
got me thinking when we were studying it
in our group Daniel 12 verse 5 says then
I Daniel looked and there stood two
others one on this riverbank and the
other on that riverbank and one said to
the man clothed in linen who who was
above the waters of the river how long
shall the fulfillment of these wonders
be so Daniel was shown a vision
to people over the river so I'm
wondering was being shown a vision of
John and talking to the angel alright
that's a great question you've got my
mind spinning but I don't think so if
you look in Daniel 10 verse 4 ok it says
now on the 24th day of the first month I
was by the side of the great river that
is the Tigris and I lifted up my eyes
and behold a certain man clothed in
linen now it's very symbolic because he
realized the Tigris is mentioned in
Genesis I think it's one of the rivers
the Euphrates that's mentioned and if
you look at the end of Ezekiel I did
that's the book just before Daniel and
I'm look trying to get the right verb
before you think it's it's a chapter
xlvii yeah healing waters in the trees
yeah you go to chapter 47 he talks about
along the bank of the river very many
trees and the it's very similar to where
it's where it talks about Revelation and
the leaves of the tree and the fruit by
the river wherever the river goes
everything lives so daniel ezekiel and
revelation kind of end with a river of
life sounds like now the Tigris was
thought of to be like in River of Life
but it's not the same Tigris that are
Euphrates that was in the Garden of Eden
ok anyway I don't know if I made things
I so I don't think that Daniel was
seeing John I think Ganga was seen the
same vision an angel that Ezekiel and
and the John saw that's talking about
this river of life in the end of time
but the whole the whole vision Daniel 10
11 12 is one vision and he has the
vision by the Tigris River but I think
that's symbolic of the River of Life
that you see in Ezekiel in Revelation
okay well that explains it all right
well it's a try hey thank you great
question
appreciate it next caller that we have
is Robert listening from Washington
Robert welcome to the program
thank you thank you thanks for calling I
was calling about the Romans 8 it's got
it mentions three laws the law of the
Spirit the law of sin and death and the
law of God I was wanting to know it is
the law of the Spirit is that equated
with the law of God or the laws Mendes
is that equated with the law of God well
the word law is sometimes Paul uses the
word to talk about kind of the rule or
the way or the principle by which the
spirit operates and when I talk by the
law of the Spirit if you are spirit
filled you will walk in the law of the
Lord because the fruits of the spirit
are you know love joy peace so forth and
you find in Galatians 5:22 I don't know
if you want to take a stab at this you
that's Ross I was reading it right here
looking at Romans chapter 8 there are
several laws referenced but I think here
Paul is emphasizing the fact that you
have the law written on stone and it
says that's the law of sin and death
meaning the wages of sin is death and in
our own strength we can keep the law and
that's why he says in verse 2 but the
law of the spirit of life in Christ
Jesus has made me free from the law of
sin and death so it is through the power
of God working within the heart of the
believer that we can't keep the law
verse 3 for what the law could not do
because it was weak through the flesh
God sending his own son in the likeness
of sin sinful flesh on account of sin
condemned sin in the flesh and here's
the point verse 4 that the righteous
requirements of the law might be
fulfilled in us who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit which is what I was saying if
you're filled with the spirit and you're
walking according to law of the Spirit
you'll be obviously if your spirit
filled you will not be lying or
worshipping other gods you know you'll
be keeping the law you're not under the
penalty of the law any more the curse of
the law so you know I think that you'd
really enjoy that study guide that we're
off
tonight talking about written in stone
the law of God and I'm gonna call for
that is 808 three five six seven four
seven you can answer the study guide
called written in stone talks about this
very important subject I think even
references Romans chapter eight in that
study guide annex world that we have is
Alan listening in Washington Alan
welcome to the program yeah I'm calling
from Iowa actually Oskaloosa Iowa okay
no I really appreciate you guys just
heard your program for the first time
tonight and I wanted to make a quick
comment your answers on forgiveness and
God's grace and mercy spot-on so I
really appreciate you guys I've got a
question pertaining to you suicide and
losing our salvation which I don't
believe that you can I had a really good
friend that loved the Lord she served
him with all her heart that she took her
life and you know I believe when we meet
the Lord I believe maybe he would say I
wasn't expecting you for another 30
years
you know why are you here now and so you
know that's my question I've studied the
scriptures I've heard what other men of
God have said on the subject and I'm
hesitant to ask because I don't want a
Christian to think they can just send
their life and still be eternally secure
but I believe that you are I believe
that we might suffer a loss of rewards
well let's talk about it for just a
minute and you are asking one of the
tough questions I think virtually
everybody listening if you've lived for
very long you've known somebody that was
a believer and for whatever reason and
in a moment of agony depression it might
have been you know chemical imbalance it
could have been medication from you know
the final stages of cancer they did
something rash and they took their life
does that mean that their entire life of
loving and serving the Lord evaporates
I think we have to be very careful not
to judge that because you know yeah God
looks on the heart we don't know
everything they were going through we
don't know what kind of pain they were
enduring and I think God is a merciful
God so we need to be careful but at the
same time it's a double-edged sword we
mustn't as you just mentioned give a
person the idea that they can say well
when I was nine years old I accepted the
Lord so I'm having a rough time now I'm
just gonna check out I'm gonna kill
myself and God will resurrect me cuz
once you're saved you can't be lost that
I think is reckless because if the last
act of your life is self murder
and if murder is a you know we're made
in the image of God and and that's
serious too so I think you know you look
at the examples in the Bible of people
that committed suicide and you have I
think I can think of three examples
you've got a hit of fell who betrayed
David and then he went out and hung
himself like Judas who betrayed Christ
and then you've got Saul
I guess there's for Saul in his
armor-bearer that fell on their swords
and in all those cases these characters
were very likely not saved
you know Saul and grieved away the Holy
Spirit Judas was you know it says Satan
entered him so you know I don't think
that we have got the only one you can
look at is maybe Samson in a sense as a
suicide in that he you know he probably
knew they were about to kill him and he
said Lord let me let me die with the
Philistines and he he stretched out his
arms like Jesus and he laid down his
life to defeat the enemies of God so
Samson will be in heaven you can read in
Hebrews 11 right so that's why I say
we've got to be very careful suicide is
I think a very bad idea
people believe that you know life is
sacred and people think that if I in my
life I'm somehow gonna assure myself
into a better existence I think in most
cases that is they're gonna be in for a
big surprise but I believe there's
exceptions and so we got to be careful
difficult question I hope I didn't give
too much of a rambling answer no you did
not and yeah and the secret things are
of the Lord Deuteronomy says that and
and I and I believe that his ways and
thoughts are higher than ours I guess
and I was hesitant to ask the question
because I've been studying the
scriptures about that it does definitely
show a lack of trust in the Lord and his
will for our lives but I just was
interested I really enjoyed your program
and well hope it's habit-forming or spot
on call us again thank you very much
next for that we have we just got a few
moments left but we got Noah listening
in Illinois know we have just a couple
of minutes here before the end of the
program yeah no problem
my question is most most families are
not Christians right oh and is anyone in
the Bible going through the same thing
as I am yeah where you're a believer
most of your family is not yeah yeah
like you've got Joseph for a while there
Joseph had 11 brothers or 10 brothers
that sold him into slavery and lied
about it
he felt pretty Forsaken even though they
went to church so to speak they claim to
believe in God they sure weren't
following God and you know I think
there's some others in the Bible that
you can point to you know when Paul when
the gospel started to go out among the
Gentiles you would have one Gentile in
the family that would convert and many
others then were not believers and they
had to try and be witnesses that's why
it says in 1st Peter that if a woman is
married to an unbeliever by her behavior
she reaches her husband friends you can
hear the music it's kind of chasing us
off the precipice we'd love to hear from
you again next week you can support this
ministry simply go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g
and click donate is that blunt enough
we'd love to have your help to stay on
the air god bless friends
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
amazing facts offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
beyond the great wall the printing and
translation of our books and video
materials are in constant motion
Southeast Ohio Bates oxygen tien-shan
Joey China - the amazing facts Chinese
language website is now one of our most
visited websites we also translated
thousands of pieces of literature for
these nations what started out as
hundreds of followers is now in the
hundreds of thousands the impact of your
funds invested in sharing the
everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come you
know every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry god bless you find out
what the critics are raving about top
scholars and theologians from around the
country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G if you'd like to enhance
your study of God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 macing fax 0 RG